notre jeunesse a du talent et c'est
peut-être grâce à quelques sélections
livre que nous nous plaisons à vous
distillez comme ça au fil du temps avec
notre spécialiste qui se trouve dans la
bibliothèque de france 3 on est très
fiers de travail ou tiphaine parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans votre bibliothèque
vous avez une sélection autour de trois
livres très différents et pourtant ils
ont un point commun ils parlent des
enfants avec leurs questionnements leurs
difficultés et leur manière de voir
l'avenir le premier album s'adresse aux
tout petits c'est ça oui j'ai choisi de
vous parler de celui là parce qu'il
parle de l'avenir de rêver l'avenir en
couleurs il s'appelle demain je serai
c'est un album de jessie caniche publié
chez gautier languereau et c'était un
album qui se place dans cette veine un
d'éducation positive alors le héros est
un petit lapin qui clame haut et fort ce
qu'il sera demain demain je serai
généreux je serai tendre je serai
serviable mais en creux et bien on
comprend que ce sont des questionnements
sur la manière d'arriver à ce point là
il faut et bien réussir ces défis il
faut réussir à accepter bien les dons
comment faire pour devenir cet être que
l'on rêve justement de devenir comment
apprendre à rendre service alors c'est
une sorte de livre en forme de mantra il
est très coloré vous le voyez alors les
enfants et bien l'accaparent se
l'accaparent très vite et puis les
écritures leur plaisent énormément alors
ce ne sont pas 1 des injonctions comme
les adultes pourrait le penser mais
plutôt une petite âme et l'audi légère
qui parle d'amour de partage et de bonne
volonté
sagem généreuse tendre serviable c'est
tout vous ça dites moi vous avez dû lire
ce bouquin à votre naissance
a adoré figurez vous bon bah oui
tenir tel fils forcément on prend un
deuxième bouquin parce que ça nous
intéresse un deuxième livre qui montre
que c'est le partage qui donne foi en
l'avenir pour bien se construire et
apparemment une phrase d'après-vous peut
provoquer un déclic tiffen et oui je
parle comme une rivière de jordan scott
et sydney smith publié aux éditions à
didier jeunesse parle du pouvoir des
mots vous savez ces mots qui peuvent
nous échapper mais qui peuvent aussi et
bien nous réconforter alors le lecteur
le jeune lecteur plonge immédiatement un
dans la tête du héros et dans cette tête
là et bien les mots résonnent fort mais
au moment de passer la barrière de la
bouche et bien il s'en mêle et c'est un
petit garçon qui a du mal à prendre la
parole en classe parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ouvre la bouche et bien ses
camarades se moquent de lui heureusement
il y à ses promenades à la rivière qui
lui offre un véritable réconfort et
c'est ce sont ces moments passés avec
son père justement qui sont des bouffées
d'oxygène et un jour son père est bien
prononce cette phrase et lui dit tu
parles comme une rivière et c'est un
déclic parce qu'il comprend que le
bégaiement ce handicap dont il souffre
est bien n'est pas un obstacle à toute
sa vie parce que la rivière crash est
qu'à haute comme le bégaiement mais elle
a aussi énormément de force alors je
vous conseille ce livre un pied un
véritable moment de poésie pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans vous verrez ça
permet de voir le bégaiement autrement
alors va rester en pleine nature aux
collines rivière d'important pour
l'ouest américain profitez-en c'est nous
qui payons avec le dernier ouvrage dans
votre bibliothèque
tiphaine une histoire entre titou et son
grand père jack c'est ça oui tout à fait
je vous ai dis hein c'est le partage qui
permet d'avancer et avec ce livre est
bien on est tout à fait là dedans ça
s'appelle fuméloise au canada publié aux
éditions otish ima et cette maison
d'édition aime proposer de nouvelles
versions de romans connu alors là c'est
l'américain jim dodge qui avait publié
un très court roman qui a eu énormément
de succès et l'illustrateur français tom
augmente a déçu et bien de proposer sa
version et on découvre l'histoire de
titou un jeune orphelin qui est
recueilli par son grand père qui est
buveurs solitaire joueurs enfin pas du
tout le genre de personne à qui on
confierait un enfant mais ces deux là
vont se construire ce co construire et
on découvre une histoire un peu
fantasque puisque titou et bien éprouvé
un grand plaisir à construire des
barrières et apprivoise un oiseau alors
les illustrations sont magnifiques et
c'est vraiment la grande force de ce
roman illustré vous voyez on découvre
des gouaches qui sont des paysages qui
nous emmène en pleine nature et puis
aussi par moments et bien des formes
plus proche de la bande dessinée je vous
conseille ce livre à partir de 13 ans et
pour tous les adultes qui rêve d'enfance
et d'avenir j'adore vous avez fait
revenir d'un coup ça j'aime la sélection
livre à retrouver évidemment aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux est forcément sur le
net france point tv pour revoir cette
séquence